Bueno pues el gobierno trata de instalar
en la gente una moral de Victoria pero
lo que detectamos aquí muchas veces es
como mucho moral ya secas nada más en el
régimen de Vladimir Putin esperaba hace
un año que se iba a tratar de una
invasión corta fugaz una operación
Relámpago que desbancase a lensky del
Poder y se ha encontrado con una guerra
larga y cruenta con ya demasiados
ataúdes volviendo a casa aquí a Rusia
desde el principio la de mi Putin ha
tratado de no despertar a la opinión
pública rusa convenciéndoles de que no
se trataba de una guerra
pero ahora que ha avanzado tantísimo el
tiempo y han pasado 12 meses Putin está
cambiando el foco y ya no hace tanto
hincapié en que se trata de una
operación militar especial para
desmitificar a un país que se estaba
convirtiendo en una amenaza para la
comunidad de Rusia sino que pone el foco
en la gran gesta que supone para Rusia
enfrentándose a occidente sobre todo a
Estados Unidos y a la otan en general no
a sus soldados pero sí a sus armas y a
su información de inteligencia en el
campo de batalla que supone Ucrania más
que un país es concebido como un campo
de batalla para ese pulso con occidente
por eso
vladin Putin igual que los rusos sabe
que se encuentra entre un año difícil
donde se van a empezar a notar las
sanciones y quiere asegurarse de que
todos los rusos están en el mismo barco
es decir sabiendo que se encuentran en
una segunda edición de la Guerra Fría
más cruenta y que aunque las los efectos
y las incomodidades de esa guerra se
noten en casa el objetivo es recuperar
la hegemonía mundial O al menos
disputarse en Estados Unidos y hacerle
perder eso que los rusos llaman el
monopolio de las relaciones
internacionales que tiene ahora
hablamos constantemente de sanciones y
hablamos de cómo occidente Está tratando
de aislar de alguna manera a Rusia pero
este impacto realmente se ha sentido en
territorio ruso
poco a poco se va notando Pero la verdad
es que las sanciones occidentales en un
primer momento han tenido un efecto
mucho menor de lo que venían pregonando
los políticos europeos por ejemplo con
Estados Unidos respecto a un posible
derrumbe de la economía rusa se ha
notado mucho por ejemplo en los precios
los precios de los productos en
productos básicos y hay que recordar que
en el caso de Rusia en la cesta de la
compra en muchos casos hay muchos
productos que vienen del extranjero
Entonces ha habido productos que en el
primer momento faltaron que después han
sido sustituidos por otros llegados de
otros lugares porque en general los
precios desde luego han subido Y eso lo
han notado bastante los rusos el segundo
componente Aunque este ya no afecta
gente son las dificultades para entrar y
salir del país un asunto que al
principio era simplemente una desventaja
desde el punto de vista del ocio del
tiempo libre pero que además se ha
convertido en un problema que atosiga
muchos recursos que en realidad no están
preocupados por sino que están
preocupados y mucho Sobre si van a poder
huir a tiempo si existe un segundo
reclutamiento una segunda movilización
como la que vimos en los meses de
septiembre y octubre los expertos
coinciden en que las sanciones harán se
notarán todavía más su efecto Durante
este año 2023 y por eso es por lo que el
kreming está en suplando tantísimo
contenido patriótico incluso no solo los
medios de comunicación sino las propias
escuelas rusas donde se piden los niños
que escriban cartas a los soldados
porque va a hacer falta mucho
Patriotismo para olvidar los dolores de
los frigorífico de la mesa del armario
donde se guarda la comida de los precios
lo que ocurre en el mercado hacer la
compra En definitiva la vida cotidiana
que se hace más difícil